wenn wir schauen auf dem prozess zum
anschlag auf die synagoge in halle
gestern wurde das video der tat vor
gericht gezeigt 36 minuten lang stimmte
stephan barth damals live wie er
versuchte in die synagoge einzudringen
und später erbarmungslos zwei menschen
tötete
gerade für die betroffenen im saal ist
das kaum auszuhalten
christina faißt war am tag des anschlags
in der synagoge
das war gestern sehr schwierig gerade
hereingeführt wurde das war natürlich ja
das erste mal dass wir einander gesehen
haben oder dass ich ihn gesehen habe ich
habe mir nicht mal fotos von ihm
angeguckt ich wusste gar nicht wie er
aussieht
ich war sehr davon überrascht dass er
eigentlich körperlich sehr klein ist
soweit ich weiss es auch kleiner als ich
es amüsiert mich zu einem guten teil um
ehrlich zu sein
insgesamt ja ich bin wenig überrascht
davon dass er sich ja hat sie wie
sanftes lächeln r lacht hin und wieder
auf ich bin wenig überrascht davon dass
er sich selbstbewusst gibt da möchte ja
auch ein schüchterner möchte seine macht
zeigen
es funktioniert hat bei mir nicht ich
kann nur für mich sprechen aber ich lass
das so nicht an mich heran und ich gebe
ihnen das auch nicht katastrophal
das war das erste mal dass ich das video
gesehen habe ich möchte das auch nie
wieder sehen
gleichzeitig war es wichtig es war
wichtig auf einer persönlichen ebene für
meine trauerverarbeitung weil es dadurch
dass ich in der synagoge war jetzt das
erste mal war dass sich quasi nicht nur
gesehen habe was außen passiert ist
sondern auch was danach noch alles
passiert ist ich kannte das ja nur aus
medienberichten von einfach die fakten
wenn man so möchte das macht jetzt noch
mal eine viel größere emotionale
verbindung auf und das andere ist
natürlich was wir in dem video gesehen
haben entbehrt aller worte also ich kann
und will das gar nicht kommentieren weil
ja das ist unbeschreiblich